المحلل الرئيسي في مركز جورج تاون للامن
والتكنولوجيا الناشئه ويليام هانس هو ضيفي
لهذه الحلقه ارحب به معكم اهلا بك معنا
سيد هانس
ون
وفقا لمقالات الخبراء فان 80% مما يحتاجه
رئيس الولايات المتحده او رئيس اركان
الجيش الامريكي لاتخاذ قرار جاد ياتي من
مصادر مفتوحه كيف هذا
ثم اسمعوا 85 بالمئه وهذا من
المصادر الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه والصينيه
فهي موثوقه وحتى قبل الانترنت او التواصل
الاجتماعي وانفجار المعلومات بشكل عام
ونفس الارقام ذكرت حينها واذا ما فكرنا
بالامر فالمساله منطقيه فمن اكثر من له
دافع لعثر المعلومات الموظف الحكومي الذي
يتلقى مرتبه مهما عمله شهريا او المراسله
الصحفي الذي تعتمد حياته على العثور على
المعلومات والانباء الموثوقه كيف يمكن ان
يثق صانعوه القرار في استخبارات
المصادر ان يثقوا بالمصادر المفتوحه حتى
في الشيء اشد الظروف قسوه
السؤال وجيه ولكن يطرح نفس السؤال على
المعلومات السريه المعلومات السريه او
الاستخبارات هي نفس الكلمه بالصينيه الذي
هم كلمه واحده او هي محفوفه بالكثير من
المشاكل من ضمنها ضعف السياق
المعلومات المظلله والابلاغ الدائري وحتى
الخداع شهدته حالات حيث بعض العملاء
يبيعون معلومات يدعون انها سريه ولكنهم في
الحقيقه حصلوا عليها مكتوبه في مقالات
الصحفيه كتبت باللغه لا يستطيع الضابط
قراءتها او يفهمها
لا المعلومات السريه ولا المسار مفتوح
يمكن تثق بها يجب ان نتحقق منها او نحللها
ونضعها في السياقه المناسب لكي تكون
موثوقه وحتى حينها بالنسبه الموثوقيه يجب
ان نتاكد منها وهنا ياتي دور الضباط
الاستخبارات وهنالك نوع من المعلومات
المفتوحه والسريه
وكلها ما يدعمه الاخر
والمصادر المفتوحه تؤكد المعلومات السريه
حسب الجهات الاستخباراتيه ولكن العلاقه في
الحقيقه هي بالعكس فهنالك تقارير قائمه
بالكامل على معلومات مفتوحه وتضاف اليها
المعلومات السريه فقط او مجرد للاضافه لكي
تؤخذ بجديه